Joe Biden sounded strange when he was
talking there was something about his
diction that didn't seem right what I'm
speculating it might be the teeth what
do you think it's the popular
combination of the teeth and so much
Botox that his entire face kid not moves
oh so you think it's a lot of maybe
corrective surgeries that have gone
horribly awry but look at the guy I mean
I think he's not got this mentis and I
just don't know how you run that when
you are personally responsible for the
mass incarceration of millions of young
black men for the nonviolent first-time
offense of possession of small amounts
of drugs that his bill used to call it
the Biden bill see if he still calls it
that yeah but more on drugs has been a
failure and who is it who is signing the
sentencing reforms that are springing
black people and poor people and the
disadvantage from jail and giving them a
second chance why that would be Donald
Trump he's not got any credit for that
either he's not getting any credit for
that no he really does I mean first of
all I think Kim Kardashian deserves a
lot of credit for for bringing the issue
to his attention and for convincing him
to make an important reform this has
been long needed and it's a great
contrast with with Joe Biden Biden was
arguing with someone there for 40
minutes in New Hampshire that is the war
on drugs they don't make success hi
where how yeah drugs are more plentiful
and available than ever drug crime is up
lives are being ruined families are
being ruined and the taxpayers are
paying a fortune to incarcerate
nonviolent people one more gemandsam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app